hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video ich war gestern mit luca
zusammen im spielwarengeschäft wir haben
das hier gewinnt die partie bei welcher
spülung spritzt das wasser
ich kenne das nicht aber ich hab' drehen
und dann habe ich die neben hier
gedrückt und das ganze natürlich das
musste ich kaufen und ein video davon
machen der papst bekommt nur für euch
nur für euch auf jeden fall alles nur
für euch hier nicht auch aber auch aber
eigentlich bei euch für euer genannt so
wird zwar kann das jetzt mal auf ski
party im moment nehmen wir uns erst mal
um den namen geht die party zu
überdenken
er mache ein spiel ist die partie die
macher von pippi passend also dass man
hier raus
man muss sogar extra kann man beim
moosburger extra batterien mittring hab
ich gemerkt ich habe dann alles bedacht
leute und jetzt brauche ich erstmal
diese toilette auf ein sehr schwieriges
erfassung komplexer auch man aber gut
herrscher stürzen können erster schritt
bitte einen erwachsenen am zusammenbau
helfen kann mir vielleicht jemand beim
aufbau helfen irgendjemand steckt sie
befestigen schien die toiletten sockels
vorsichtig durch die öffnung die sich im
spielboden befinden kann man den
wasserkasten 15 jetzt gleich irgendwie
so dass ihr das hier drehen ametrin
gucken wie oft wir spielen müssen
dreimal ja irgendwie kann man sich hier
mit wasser voll
ist der something of people away to the
press and repair geil wenn sie jetzt ein
wechsel ist die leichte alles was
passieren gezogen aus reporter cathy was
ich brauche keinen erwachsenen er mich
schon großen großer junge erwachsene
merkmal ist der unterschied
ich war unten ich hab ich ein wenn man
2010 bestimmt man aber sagen haben
total rang 16 im zweiten batterie mit
ich schaue mir auch wenn die darin auch
ein video versehen weil zwei blöcke
anfangen tag des spiels noch unter
[Applaus]
macht euch bereit achte darauf dass die
toiletten deckel hochgeklappt für die
touristische bis zur markierung sauberem
leitungswasser bereits die toilette zum
spiel vor betätigt die schülerin die mit
den hebel drückt das wasser beginn
heraus zu spritzen so dass das ding es
machen natürlich nicht einfach mit
normaler reiseverkehr prix party mit
leitungswasser partie besser als
lebensmittel abholt partie war sie hatte
für die farbe rot für sie ja mit ihr
leben zufällig und bad vilbel schön mit
den frauen die auf natürliche kraft ist
der weg ins gebrochen moll weiter sinken
in der brocken bringen sind wir dass sie
noch nicht die die schnauze davon männer
brauchen drin
generell ist lebensmittel wahrscheinlich
nicht so super stau weil man dann geld
wird einfach normales wasser rein dann
gehen wir dann liegen aber auch ihr ziel
verfehlen wir anfingen nur leute ich das
ist mein gewicht hierhin machen
ohne spaß wenn man video das okay aber
kennt ihren menschen das geld dafür
bezahlt hat dass man das machen kann
sind wohl vom schwerer als wir drehen
jetzt mal machen noch einmal als jeder
dritte verfahren hat die clique aus dem
kiosk gibt
meine damen und herren ich drehe hier
auch zum ersten mal diese scheibe jetzt
und wir sehen eine zweite platz war erst
zwei jahren knapp also freunde ich weiß
nicht wie weit man das vorher drauf wo
sie wegen den dingen luca traktiert
jetzt bin ich wieder dran mit der pfote
momentan dreht
wir haben eine rein und richtig geklemmt
als das erklärt kittler mit viel lust
dazu erstmal drin vielleicht wieder nach
der 2 auf dieses video und ich habe
jetzt schon fünfmal soviel gedrehten du
hast mein like freilich war da dieses
video mit niedrig dreimal nein dreimal
drehen muss ich bin der boss luca dran
schon drei mal gedrückt das heißt wenn
wahrscheinlich wenn es jetzt auch noch
eine 1 direkt am hafen eine spannende
wie es heißt
die vorgaben geben wenn es drauf ankommt
schlimmer daraus nicht als wenn ist und
was die leute die jetzt wieder
wahrscheinlich ewig eine 3 von daher
okay es bei diesmal meine damen herren
es geht los ich bin nicht so krass und
drückt so dass bester film zu drehen
weil ja gerade schon ja wo es vielleicht
einfach zweimal direkt hintereinander
bekommt plötzlich auch noch kein
vertrauen
[Applaus]
etwas für dich schwierig ich habe mich
damit gemacht ich habe noch kein mal ne
einzelhändler okay wenn jetzt wasser
raus kommt leute hier dann heule ich
dann spiele ich nicht mehr mit ihr als
auch man aber es ist immer wieder immer
nur da ist niemand gesagt wer ja ja ich
will die mitmachenden der fläche musste
er die kriterien die presse über
jedenfalls der fall also wir machen
einfach nämlich widerstände er geraten
wenn ihre akkus würfel du musst nicht
mehr dann willst du kannst mir einfach
zu fragen
aber es gibt halt kein ändern wenn ein
kluger durch ein zweckbetrieb auch bei
einsätzen geküsst
ich lasse und jungen ganz knapp an die
drei verweise ich meine passierte lösung
[Musik]
jetzt kommen
er kam haben wir die auch hier raus ja
glatt geworden
da darf auch und zugespitzt nein ich hab
mich erschrocken wenn ich kann er bei -
kommt so leute machen mit schauder und
rechtes showdown abwechselnd ohne drehen
und damit das video vorbei leute wir
machen das jetzt so lange wird bei einem
rutsch komprimierte wahrscheinlich nicht
verkraften hatte
[Applaus]
jetzt genau jetzt leute ich kenne dieses
spiel genau jetzt auch gar nicht mehr
sagen aber wenn ich jetzt nicht
rausgekommen bekommt wenn die leute ich
glaube ich sagen
länderspiel machte das gefühl sagt ma
lin antwort nicht viel spaß machen im
video von mir zu machen dann würde ich
auch sagen das war vom heutigen video
das war kein produktplatzierung oder
sonstwie sondern es ist einfach so durch
dass leute wie wir machen müssen noch
mal ein video wollt wo ich irgendwie nix
oder so was mit dem ding mache schreibt
in die kommentare
da sind wir nicht mal wieder das gerne
glauben
so etwas eigentlich zum 1 abonnieren
kann abonniert haben dass auch das alte
video ja genau da soll noch mal machen